Reggie Miller the hall of famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst as the Finals games
will be on ABC who do you like in the
series reg to me it really will come
down to Game one I know obviously it's a
seven-game series the first to win four
but Game one is so important in my
opinion to Toronto if they win Game one
I see this being a long series
if Golden State finds the way to get
Game one this could be a gentlemen sweep
in five and not knowing the availability
of KD I know he's been ruled out of Game
one I'm just gonna go on the record and
say that he is not playing in this
series and the only reason why I say
that if you look at that video of him
walking to the plane he still has a limp
in that gate and if you're expecting a
player of Kevin Durant's caliber to play
out such a high level like you know
Finals MVP like he was the last two
years I just that walk that tells me
he's not coming back I could be very
much wrong I just don't see him coming
back in this series and I thought
truthfully I think the Warriors caught a
break by getting Toronto I thought
Milwaukee I had Milwaukee went in at all
they had more weapons but what Kauai has
done he was the best player in that
series I didn't think he had enough
weapons around him now those guys made
shots Lowry you know woke up Van Vleet
showed up in the series late after you
know games three through six but is that
enough to be Golden State I don't know
Game one to me will tell me everything I
need to know about this series have you
had that injury before the KD has I've
never had a calf injury and when it
again I Kevin Harlan on myself we called
that game and as soon as it happened I
thought my first instinct was Achilles
because the way he looked back at it I
thought it was his Achilles obviously it
came out that it was his calf but I know
it would be this serious I thought he
would be back in that Portland sir
and then for them to have what ten plus
days off after they swept Portland and
he's still not ready for Game one and
then when I saw him walking to the plane
I'm like he's not playing now with that
now with that walk now with that limp
again I could be totally wrong but I
just do not see him coming back in this
series well I don't see him playing the
first two games in Toronto I'm surprised
he went to Toronto it feels like Katie
that if he's going to play they're gonna
try to bring him back when they lose a
game but if they lose Game one you know
does Katie play in Toronto and I I don't
think that's gonna be the case it felt
like in in the Portland series hey well
yeah but you know are you gonna need him
in this series if you win the first two
games in Toronto we may not see Kevin
Durant the rest of this series and maybe
the last time we'll see him in a Golden
State uniform Doc Rivers had some
interesting things to say about Kauai he
said he's the most like Jordan that
we've seen not that he is Jordan or
anything like that but he's the most
like him big hands post game can finish
great leaper great defender you know he
beat you to the spot bumps you off
three-point shooting as well what do you
make of that compliment by Doc Rivers
who might be his coach next season I
concur
and I think doc was listen to our
telecast cuz I said that on air that he
was as close to Jordan I guess you would
put Kobe in that as well and to me you
know please people understand what I'm
saying here it's not the leaping ability
and the fadeaway that Jordan had but
being able to play being a two-way
player and we talked about the big hands
if you want the fundamentals of Kobe
bean Bryant and Kawhi Leonard they are
so fundamentally sound I'm talking about
footwork both have impeccable footwork
especially in the post on the perimeter
they both can take you off the balance
and yes
Kawhi has that fade away but it's the
hands he separates himself
when you come to double him a lot like
what Michael Jordan did she would always
attack the double with the guy that was
coming down and most of the time the
guys that were doubling him
were the bigs so he would attack the
bigs we call it attacking the double
bigs so the big would come down to
double and he would basically use the
guy coming down to double as like a
screen or a brush screen to get his shot
off quiet does the same thing almost in
the same manner ISM so I understand what
doc could say I see it I said that on
air people looked at me crazy but I
absolutely but watch the footwork in the
finals
unbelievable footwork a lot like Kobe
bean Steph is the Vegas favored to win
the finals MVP if I gave you Steph Curry
or the field will you take it I am
taking Steph Curry in this if Kevin
Durant does not come back obviously if
Golden State wins I'm taking because you
could have made a case last year for him
to win Finals MVP I know the first year
was definitely Kevin Durant yeah but you
could have gone back and forth between
that Finals MVP between Steph and Katie
Katie ended up went in to win
back-to-back Finals MVP but if the
Golden State Warriors win and what he's
done the last six games without KD the
only thing that could be a wrinkle in
this there's been a lot of time off for
Golden State and the whole adage of rust
versus rest I think will play a factor
here especially for a shooter for a
shooter you want to keep your rhythm you
want to just keep it going
if you're Steve Kerr and Golden State
you wish you could have played what two
or three days later but they've been off
what ten plus days and as a shooter your
mind drifts you can go through all the
drills you want but you've got to have
that game time rhythm so that could be
the only thing in Game one that may
throw him off he'll eventually get that
rhythm but I like Vegas odds and I would
go with Steph as well talking to red the
Warriors when talking to Reggie Miller
the hall-of-famer Turner Sports NBA
analyst the first free agent to announce
where he's going will be who
I would probably say Kyrie Irving it
just did not end well in Boston right
yeah all season long the body language
the moodiness not on Kyrie part but all
of the Celtics something just did not
feel right and I would not be surprised
I know they've like lifted it a day now
it's June 30th I believe is when you can
actually announce I wouldn't be
surprised if it's June 25th Kyrie says
I'm afraid I'm going somewhere else well
let me make you their agent let your
kairi's agent where where would you
advise him to go I could see him
reteaming with LeBron in LA I really can
okay he made the experiment and
rightfully so every player has this
right to do this he wanted to see if he
could lead a team be the man be top dog
it didn't work out and I love Kyrie
I was lights and uncle drew but in my
opinion Kyrie
could be one of the greatest Scottie
Pippen's ever to a Michael Jordan he is
that good I just don't think he's dead
number one but if I put Kyrie with
LeBron and I brought in Jimmy Butler I
like him now what do I have with the
Lakers you have a top four team that can
compete you have a top four team in the
in the West can they win it all I mean
you know things have to happen you got
to have brakes
injuries can happen but I like that team
but are you trading anybody and I'm
keeping Kyle Kuzma of all the Lakers I'm
keeping Kyle Kuzma okay you can get rid
of everyone else yeah but I don't think
that works that way reg because if I if
I'm going to be and you could pack their
bags for them along as they keep Kyle
Kuzma I'm alright with that okay you're
advising Kevin Durant see I think the
injury helps Golden State
because if they go on to win and
three-peat without KD I think he comes
back maybe signs of another one-year
deal it has a chance to go for a 4-pete
something Michael Jordan never did now
you're in the same breath with the 60s
and the Celtics of total domination I
think if you've been playing and they
wanted to repeat he was gone
regardless but reg but why don't I just
say hey KD thank you and then I let him
go and I bring in somebody who wants to
be there for three or four years or five
years and I paid them the money and I
got somebody who actually wants to be
there and then there's no games I don't
have to deal with any drama and as great
as KD is we just won the title without
him what do you think it's gonna happen
if KD leaves and cly Leonard tends to go
this day wait and Copeland Kauai goes to
Golden State have you oh yes I have I
said that yesterday if I'm quiet
I go to Masai Ujiri the general manager
and said I did something that Vince
Carter Tracy McGrady demar derozan
know what Chris Bosh Damon Stoudamire no
one's ever done two things that will be
known for the Raptors that shot in the
corner the the four toucher touched me
in the morning and getting to the NBA
Finals win or lose I think he goes to
him and says I did my job thank you very
much I'm out and if Katie decides he
doesn't want to read up and go to state
would you not be surprised definite his
mannerisms fit Golden State
well I'm also wondering because I said
this just because if Golden State loses
Kevin Durant they're not gonna sit there
and mope they're gonna they're gonna go
out against it they went out and got
boogie cousins and surprise to everybody
they're not gonna just sit there and go
oh woe is me we lost KD they're gonna be
like anybody else want to play well
fast-paced tempo with two of the
greatest shooters of all time
Hall of Fame coach clay has a decision
as well I mean him not making all-nba
and not getting the Supermax which I
thought he should have been on an
all-nba team but I get it
but who would you take off are you
taking you taking him
Kemba would not be surprised of clay
bounces they were all predicated if they
win let's say they win oh let's say they
win
what is Golden State what's it what's
Golden State look like next year in your
opinion well you know they have stuff I
think they may get boogie at a bargain
basement because of the injury and then
after that again I think the injury
helps them with Kevin Durant especially
if they win if they win I think he comes
back one year let's go for a 4-pete now
we're in the same breath as the Celtics
we will leapfrog the the Bulls winning
four in a row I think they go after that
I don't think you want to wait and go to
like the Knicks one year after that when
somebody's already made it dances the
Knicks lost everything everything when
they didn't get the number one pick in
Zion William you don't think Katie's
going to the Knicks no not now I don't I
think everything was set up number one
pick
Zion Williams and Katie maybe Kyrie when
the Knicks failed a three no I just
don't the roster set up why go there and
struggle winning is a drug he is
addicted down to winning and being in it
why go to the Knicks and a sensitive as
Katie can be at times with Golden
State's media could you imagine going to
New York in that New York media and you
have one two maybe three bad games what
they're going to say stay where you are
get a chance to go for a for beating you
may win this year how do you think magic
is handled the Lakers situation since he
stepped down well I knew the
backstabbing
the character assassination would come
out sooner or later you know they're
coming out that he mistreated employees
which I think that that article does a
disservice to the Lakers because I don't
want to hear some staffer I want to hear
names okay
is this a staffer that was already fired
or a staffer that's still working for
the Lakers because if you still working
for the Lakers you have a snitch in your
organization so for them to come out and
say magic was mistreating the employees
you could talk about his X's and O's who
he drafted not surrounding LeBron with
shooters I get all that that's part of
his job description but to go after a
guy's character and then you don't put
names behind it but you you say Magic
Johnson this Magic Johnson bad and I
talked to a staffer know don't want to
hear it I want names
who said that about magic in the front
office okay because that person needs to
be held accountable as well so where's
Jeannie busting all this right the whole
Rob pálinka not being able to trust I
can see that people not trusting Rob
palinka I can see what magic said about
I can see that being in it and and kind
of knowing Rob I can see it what do you
mean I could see Rob being I could see
Rob saying stuff about magic being a
backstabber I could understand that if
magic said that because magic is a
straight-shooter right but are you
basing it off experience I'm basing it
off I I know magic and the one thing
that I've known about him from my
freshman year at UCLA he has never ever
lied to me now he's never sugar-coated
anything he told me when things have
been good and he's told me when things
have been awfully bad he's been brutally
honest with me along with Michael Cooper
along with Byron Scott those guys raised
me at UCLA so when he says that Rob was
backstabbing I'm going to tend to
believe that when he is holding staffers
or people in the front office
accountable and he's given them tough
talk and they don't like it
I tend to believe that he's being a
straight shooter so yes that's when I
say about Rob polenka and other people
in around the league don't trust him I
can see that yeah the only thing is that
you know these voices and they're
they're just voices they're not names is
you know they they feel like if their
names are mentioned or they put their
jobs in jeopardy or nobody listen to
them because it's Magic Johnson like I
understand those who don't want to come
forward with their name attached to it
because you know this is magic and it's
still magic way out I don't wanna look
if you're brave enough to speak to a
reporter put your name to it put your
name to it can't just say Magic Johnson
and that's it Medus I get what people
are pressure was magic because on the
flip side magic never should have done
that press conference magic never should
win and just straight said I'm out he
should have went to genie foresters and
he is a smart astute businessman if
someone have done this in one of his
businesses he would have been outraged
well they should've hired him in the
first place though reg I'm not letting
magic off the hook here yeah what I'm
upset about is you can't go after
someone's character and not put your
name behind it okay the Lakers have
someone in their organization who's
continuing to talk that's the problem
with the Lakers and this is going to
hurt them in free agency because who do
you trust
we're who is the hierarchy there I'm not
hearing anything from Genie bus
yeah that's part of the problem make the
right there's no leader there's no
leader reg that's the proper
Linda rebus I mean who's running things
you done you know I knew I knew it was
going to come out that people were gonna
bad talk magic bad talk about his
decisions about him drafting about him
not sir you know talk about the actions
of those don't talk about him
mistreating employ
come on man don't start that put the
name behind it and then I'll be like
okay all right such a said said this now
what
Thank You reg sunburn over Memorial Day
what was that on your chest by the way
what was that I was going to a sporting
event I was painting my stomach and then
I was gonna put a deal I was going to
the New Jersey Devils game and I was
just going to put a D on there okay do
you get sunburned come on I got the best
skin black don't crack
and we bronze oh you burn I burn baby I
don't burn I burn baby burn
Thank You reg wait for next week so we
can see what's going on in this theory
Thank You bud that's Reggie Aloysius
Miller jr. the third for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]